c'était en octobre durant le colloque
scientifique sur le chlordécone
le représentant de la direction de
l'agriculture et des forêts faisait
cette annonce pour la viande était
décidé en réunion interministérielle de
modifier les maires de la mettre à un
niveau plus faible de 0,02
mirant parking quatre mois plus tard un
arrêté ministériel fixe donc le taux
maximum de chlordécone dans la viande
dite lmr à 27 microgrammes par kilo une
avancée pas vraiment d'une part avant la
hausse de 2013 cette limite maximale de
résidus était fixé à 20 microgrammes
nous ne sommes donc même pas revenu au
temps intérieure alors que de nombreuses
voix demandent toujours le taux zéro
pour ce perturbateur endocrinien
deuxième déception l'arrêté ne concerne
que la viande bovine ce qui avait durant
le colloque déjà conduit le
fonctionnaire de la rs eric godard a
protesté
c'est une précaution qu'on navigue d'un
jeune dont les bovins pourquoi ne pas
l'appliquer également pour les poussins
les ovins les caprins et les malades
dans la lmr je le rappelle est toujours
fixée à 100 du programme dans le muscle
dans le foie est il dans la glace
on n'est pas du tout dans l'attribution
et comme vous l'avez dit la lumière
s'éteindra cantabile l'aliment jusqu'à
ce niveau ont droit à une protection
vaccinale réponse lui avait été faite
que la baisse des taux était à l'étude
pour les ovins caprins et la volaille
des études qui prennent apparemment
beaucoup de temps bien que les données
soient déjà disponibles pour rappel le
taux autorisé dans la volaille est
aujourd'hui de 200 microgrammes de
chlordécone par kg pour un enfant de dix
kilos il suffit de 50 g de poulets
contaminés à ce niveau pour dépasser la
dose journalière considéré comme
dangereuse